my name is andrew foy uh a-n-d-r-e-w
and foys f-o-y okay so
in a nutshell how would you describe
your
youtube channel uh it is a
i think it's a place that a ton of
people come
to enjoy the covers that i do uh it's
like a really really sweet community
uh all the people there i've never
gotten hate but i don't want to be like
i've never gotten hate i'm so cool but
but they're just really nice people and
i i don't do anything
that's controversial like some other
youtubers right
uh so all my stuff is super clean and pg
so
i think it's a pretty healthy channel uh
and
the people there really enjoy what i do
and they continue to support me and
they've done that for
so long now and i i'm super grateful for
that
for you like what drew you to
fingerstyle because you've been playing
since you were nine or earlier oh yeah
it was definitely nine
and i'm 19 now so uh it's been a while
but uh
it was it was my dad actually uh because
i wasn't very sports inclined at all
when i was like nine so uh he thought
that maybe instruments were the way to
go so he gave me a guitar like a super
cheap like
like 90 dollar yamaha and
and then uh like right away i picked it
up like uh rather than anything else
i kind of enjoyed it actually like uh i
didn't actually enjoy munch
but i did enjoy guitar so uh
he's the one that did all this for me
did you like look it up where did that
influence come from
uh so it was actually a really long
process of uh going to like
guitar teachers and and like other
mentors
uh like and with that study different uh
playing styles like classical guitar and
electric and acoustic
and then at one point i i saw this guy
named kelly
and he's this awesome dude he creates
these tutorials
for guitarists and he he writes the tabs
which is the the
music notation and everything and uh you
just do a little subscription and i i
did it and uh
that's how i i found that genre of a
fingerstyle and
i continued just copying literally
copying what he did
for maybe three or four years because
uh copying someone is definitely a great
way to learn
like it was probably for me the best way
to learn yeah you know
after creating all of these videos over
the past 10 years or so
what has changed what do you think is
the biggest change
and what has stayed the same for you uh
back then a lot of people didn't
uh watch me for anything else but
my guitar but now people like enjoy
who i am they like my personality i've
done like vlog videos q as lot lots of
uh like audience engaging videos
uh so they get to know me because i've
never done that in like the past
like seven years prior i never had done
anything like that
so uh in that like roughly like that
like seven
six years i uh i just did the same thing
and uh what really changed
was probably my the amount of subs that
i had
so it was it was like definitely
snowball uh so in freshman year
i had eighth grade going into freshman
year at 100k
subscribers and immediately
to the the next year in school it was a
million
and it was definitely just growing
exponentially
and it continued to grow after that
after the next year was another million
and we celebrated that
and it was uh that was amazing and now
it's it's almost
uh three million so i i think i've found
something that that works and people
like
something that people really enjoy and
uh
i i don't think i'll be you know
stopping anytime soon what is that
balance like between
you know obviously focusing on the music
and your artistry with that
and then also bringing in parts of your
life like
your sister your hamster what is that
like um
so i started off 100 uh guitar videos
and then my dad was like oh i'm looking
at all these other youtubers
and uh you know since i was still young
uh and he was like you should
maybe you should do other types of
videos to engage other types of people
that are looking for something else and
that that's definitely started uh
that pushed the channel in a different
direction and it definitely
helped because those videos have done
really well what is it like working with
your family because
clearly your dad is very supportive of
what you do and is you know engaging
with these ideas and now you're doing
some videos with your sister
what has that been like oh uh my dad has
been amazing he's like
he's led me in such an amazing path and
he's built something so
um like great for me uh like
it it it's it's gonna help me lead a
more successful life
uh because i have this foundation to
build upon i actually really enjoy
working with my sister uh because well
we're like
we're best friends like a lot of
siblings are
angry at each other right but we are
very close
and uh very chill so we're able to do
these videos without
without any conflict and uh it goes
pretty smoothly but
i would say uh my dad does like to be
a little uh strict and uh
uh ensure that we're we're doing the
best that we can
but that's just for us so uh i i think
it's beneficial
let's talk about your fans so you have
nearly three million subscribers
over the past nine years you know it it
seems like some of them maybe have
watched you grow up
watched you go through different phases
of your life tell me about your
relationship with your fans
oh so i i'll always get these comments
uh and it'll be like i've been watching
since 100k i've been watching since you
were 10 years old
and uh but i've also got people that
have been like saying
i've been watching you since i was 11.
so like like we have this like really
close connection like like all people
like people been watching me
and i've been supporting these videos
for these people and uh
i i think that uh
the content that i that i push out is uh
it's not like it's not very easy to
connect to me because it's just music
but they still do find a way like in the
comments they will joke and make
like like little memes and jokes and uh
it's really funny and i i always
uh you can look at all my videos i
always try to respond
uh as much as i can for each video and i
think that really helps too because
people know
that i i'm actually there and i'm
someone they can talk to
uh someone that they watch that they
they can talk to you know
yeah yeah do you have any people in
vegas that have
like recognized you or like said hey
vegas
uh yes definitely uh a few people it's
it's it's
uncommon but it does happen when i'll go
to like a really busy mall
but this was this was before sure yeah
so i i would go to a really busy mall
and definitely there'd be
there'd be like a group of friends and
within that group there'd be like
that friend that that watched my videos
and they would come up to me and then
they would like
ask her for a picture and stuff and it's
just so cool
that it's it's like actually real and
it's
it's something that that affects me uh
in my
my my life besides like virtually over
the internet
sure so it's it's a really good it's a
really nice like
reward to know that people uh are
watching
yeah and and that i guess they they they
know me
it feels nice for you know you're in
school
you're creating this music that's very
you know high quality like
takes time to do that how do you balance
your life
with your virtual life if i'm going to
be honest uh
my my last year wasn't so good in school
but
you know i i've been uh really working
at that i uh
i have i've been diagnosed with adb so
i've had this
this problem with school for a little
bit but
i've always like overcame it like with
the help of my
my parents for for like college right
now um
it's definitely hard to balance but it's
not impossible like like i
my friend ursha she's working two
three jobs with school that
i wouldn't do that but she can so i can
do this
you know you can find the time to do
this even though sometimes it might not
be pleasant but
uh you know the the end result is always
is it's always better than anything you
could you know want
yeah it's good to have that perspective
too and
for you know some people make money off
of their videos like that's their
livelihood is that similar for you like
how does that work
yes definitely it's uh i tell people
they
a lot of people will ask me about
questions about youtube and uh
one of the first questions would be like
how much money do you make what's your
what's your adsense and revenue
and i'm like it's guys it's literally
the same
as a normal job that you would have
maybe just better because i can control
my hours and i control
you know what content i put out and when
but uh uh it's nearly the same as a
normal like full-time job
uh and and i i i genuinely i use the
money that
i i get from this for college
and for my car for for things that i
like essentials
uh and i'm also saving up for for
emergencies and for maybe a home
uh it's just it's such an important part
of my life and it's
definitely helping me get to where i
want to be and
if i keep working at it i i know it's
it's just going to get better you know
when it comes to pandemic it's impacted
everything
you're doing virtual school we're
wearing masks um
how has it impacted your your content in
your channel if at all
so luckily i'm one of the channels that
isn't affected by covet because
i just do with my family and i'm always
with my family there's no chance of
really really communicating and diseases
uh
so there's no worries there for me and
uh it hasn't
stopped my ability to make videos at all
at all so do you think
more like have more people started
watching maybe since the pandemic i
don't know i feel like i'm online way
more
absolutely like the watch time has
increased
like you can go into the youtube studio
and and see your analytics and
something that i can definitely see
because of this pandemic is that people
are in more
and they are watching more videos and
also watching the videos for a longer
duration
and you can actually you can actually
see how long like the average time
i think mine is around one minute 45
which is
actually very good considering all the
people that will just click on
randomly and the people that maybe not
do not know me
that's still a decent uh watch time
actually what is the youtube community
like in las vegas for you because
do you know any other content creators
because there are some here but it seems
like it's not as like big of a
community i guess as la would be or
something like that oh absolutely i've
uh
i've kind of struggled to find anyone in
vegas that does youtube
uh because there just isn't that many
people that
i don't know like the chances that we
would you know
uh the chances that we would meet up or
communicate
is pretty low because i do like a
specific genre and a lot of creators
like to meet with creators that do
something similar to themselves
and i don't have many people that do
something like like me
uh so it's it's been sparse
yeah yes but i've been to like uh la and
stuff
i've made a few trips over there and
i've met a ton of people
uh like like actual people that that
have these like like musical backgrounds
and
and have made these like amazing songs
but they all live in la
so uh i'm kind of uh limited here but
also las vegas is a great place it's a
great start so many people have gotten a
great start here like a
uh what the killers imagine dragons like
come on that's
that's crazy household name oh yeah
absolutely i listen to killers all the
time like
they're great yeah so uh it's definitely
not
uh impossible to to uh
be found and for people people to find
you yeah
definitely and for you know for your
channel
what's next for you like is there a
project you really want to work on a
song you really want to do you just
haven't
done it yet like what is up and coming
for you
i believe that i uh my next thing my
next big thing is probably
creating original music a lot of people
a lot of people have been asking me for
original music but a lot of people are
asking me for
fingerstyle originals which uh i can
definitely do
i just uh i haven't had the
the courage to to create like an actual
song yet
and i'm still learning music so i i'll
get there eventually and i'm working
towards it but uh that's probably the
direction i'll go in
and uh for now i'm just going to
continue making my videos maybe uh
slowly
upping the quality i always want to make
my videos as high quality as i can i'm
actually talking to this uh
this mixer in uh in the netherlands and
he said he would he would mix my stuff
and he
he works for for a tv station and uh
i mean a new station uh and uh he makes
this for them so
he offered from from from me and uh
i think that's really going to help up
my uh channel quality
uh we already have a you know a decent
camera we got some
some good mice but uh what i really like
is
uh my mixing ability i'm not a
professional uh
my producing capabilities are quite
limited
but uh i still try to do as as well as i
can
and i think that's just gonna up the
quality and really help me out
is there anything else that you wanna
add maybe i guess you know
is this obviously music is going to be a
part of your life forever
yeah but is this you know do you want to
keep growing and growing your youtube
channel like what do you hope for your
music
career um i definitely hope to continue
doing the finger style and the the
singing covers with my
with my sister because those are doing
really well and people
love her they just they just really like
they're just taking onto her really well
but i would also like to maybe slip in
some more casual videos like
uh maybe not like a full vlog but but
something like that
uh something similar to that because
those also do well
and that's a another way people could
see who i am
and see who my family is and stuff like
that and and uh
grow closer to the channel yeah awesome
there's anything else that you want to
add andrew anything i didn't ask about
that you want to
get across yes there's this amazing
amazing uh a charity uh
it's for it's for kids that want to
learn music it's called positively acts
and uh what what they're doing is they
they uh bring in kids no matter what
their financial situation is right or if
their ability to pay
and uh they will take them in and uh
they will teach them how to produce
how to mix how to sing how to play
instruments and it's amazing i i am
going to volunteer there um because
those kids
are amazing and they want to do what i
do
and they can they just don't know how
and this class teaches them so
uh i really hope that more people could
maybe know about that
because uh actually
they have like this grammy-winning
producer right so he's he's definitely
helping out
uh with you know the publicity and
everything but it's definitely a little
small
and it does need a little help